one of the biggest challenges Facebook
faces is to keep people and businesses
happy with continuously driving change
in its functionality recently new
challenges have been added in this light
of privacy of user data and fake news
the engine of Facebook's platform to
drive all these changes is the Facebook
algorithm understanding Facebook without
understanding the Facebook algorithm
will limit you in efforts to use
Facebook successfully by the end of this
lesson you will be able to discuss two
recent news feed changes to explain the
concept of organic reach in Facebook
explained the new Facebook algorithm and
its main components identify the three
active interactions in the Facebook
algorithm and discuss the future of the
Facebook newsfeed the Facebook algorithm
is Facebook's secret sauce in which is
decided which post to show in your
newsfeed whether it's your friends post
or a post from a business Facebook has
recently announced a cleanup of the
newsfeed which particularly affects how
businesses should use Facebook it is now
commonly understood by businesses that
to use Facebook successfully they have
to pay to play in this lesson you will
learn about these Facebook changes in
the algorithm and what you can do to
improve your organic reach and we will
close the lesson with looking at the
future of the news feeds the Facebook
newsfeed and organic reach the Facebook
newsfeed is the core of the Facebook
platform it was launched as far back as
2006 and it has seen many iterations
since initially the newsfeed was the
place to see post from your Facebook
friends it was the Facebook way to stay
up-to-date and the Facebook algorithm
decides which post show up in what order
on top of the feed you see the what's on
your mind
in which you can do your own status
updates and it allows you to add photos
videos tech people check in and
so on Facebook continuously add new
features that you can add to your
updates newsfeed is the place where you
can see the activities of your friends
and the pages that you follow you can
access the newsfeed on the mobile app or
on your desktop I'm gonna show here how
to access your newsfeed on the desktop
by clicking here on the home button you
get access to your newsfeed and in the
newsfeed you can see all the posts on
the top of the newsfeed you have your
create post section we'll come back to
that later and then immediately below
that you can see the post of the various
companies that you follow all the people
that that are your friends and obviously
the Facebook algorithm and that's what
we're talking about in this module will
decide which posts it will show based on
your activities of your friends how
engaging are their posts and how many
comments are they getting on their post
and that it's a whole sort of
calculation that Facebook does to make
sure it shows the most engaging post in
your newsfeed you can see how many likes
they get how many comments so you see
this is a very engaging post and you can
like comment share the post yourself if
I click on the company name for instance
here then I would go to the company page
and then on the company page I can see
all the posts that company has done and
not necessarily although space that made
posts have made it to your news feeds
companies can use Facebook by setting up
a Facebook page and get people to like
the page and become a fan posts done by
the company would then show up in the
news feed of their fans in the early
days of the Facebook pages this was like
the gold rush of the 18th century in
America companies like coca-cola got
tens of millions of fans and had a
tremendous exposure on Facebook
and all for free but when Facebook
started to monetize their business
through advertising they need to find a
way to push businesses in using Facebook
advertising the way they did this was to
slowly erode the organic reach in
Facebook let's look at this organic
reach in a bit more detail on this slide
you see how organic Reach has dropped
over the years and how the Facebook
share price has increased they are
clearly related the share price has gone
up because a continuous drop in organic
Reach forced businesses to use Facebook
advertising to reach their audiences and
this strategy clearly works
what started as small-scale advertising
opportunities for businesses on the side
of the newsfeed than in the newsfeed and
then on the mobile next businesses could
advertising videos and with the
acquisition of Instagram and the launch
of the new facebook messenger new
advertising opportunities emerge for
businesses but his drive towards growing
advertising revenues came at a price
where the newsfeed once was the place
where friends posted updates on what
they were doing it became a garbage bin
of business posts ads drivel videos fake
news quotes and other irrelevant stuff
practically impossible for the algorithm
to manage you may have noticed this
yourself when you checked your newsfeed
over the years it used to be a place
where your friends shared what they were
doing and it became a place where you
could find stuff that the Facebook
algorithm believed you liked Facebook
knew it had to do something about this
the growth in new users are slowing down
there was an increase in fake accounts
fake ads and fake news and on top of
that there were many issues on data
privacy that got reinforced because of
the introduction of the gdpr so it was
time for a change the Facebook algorithm
today January 13th 2018 goes into the
Facebook history as a significant day
so much so that Facebook lost nearly one
hundred and nineteen billion dollars
market value in one day it was today
that Facebook announced to clean up the
newsfeed cyka Berg said in a statement
that they got feedback from their
community that public content like posts
from businesses brands and media are
crowding out the personal moments that
lead people to connect with each other
sukkah Berg continues that it's easy to
understand how he got their video and
other public content have exploded on
Facebook in the last few years but what
he doesn't say is that Facebook is a big
culprit itself in polluting the news
feeds by pushing more and more
businesses into advertising and by
offering more and more places on
Facebook Instagram and messenger to
advertise and all this pollution of the
Facebook newsfeed is driving facebook
away from the most important thing it
does helping people to connect with each
other to cut a long story short Facebook
has dropped organic reach to less than
3% and businesses now understands that
they have to pay to play or in other
words use Facebook advertising to reach
their audience so we're in the early
years of the Facebook page you could
build your audience and your brand
organically on Facebook and then use
Facebook ads to give your reach a boost
nowadays you have to pay to play but
don't let it scare you it doesn't have
to be expensive and Facebook has created
an amazing advertising platform that can
help you achieve your business goals and
don't worry there are still ways that
you can beat the Facebook algorithm and
improve your organic reach in the next
few slides and lessons we will explain
you how to do this so let's look at
today's Facebook algorithm in a bit more
detail the Facebook algorithm has to
make sure that it selects the most
relevant posts for you from the
thousands of potential posts that may be
displayed in your newsfeed
it analyzes the posts and arranges them
in a way that you would like to see them
its aim is to give you a better overall
experience it does this by looking at
four different elements it looks at all
the available posts it analyzes these
posts on various factors called signals
and it predicts how you would react to
the posts it then summarizes all this
with a score and the posts with the
highest score will feature higher in
your news feeds let me explain the
signals to you on the next slide these
are the signals Facebook looked at
before the clean up announcement time
spent on the content overall engagement
when it was posted story type how
informative is to post but with the
clean up Facebook fine-tuned the
algorithm and here is what it's looking
for now the Facebook algorithm will now
put extra focus on the engagement on a
post and the usage of other Facebook
tools like Facebook life or facebook
Messenger
which means business posts that do not
drive engagement like commenting and
sharing will not show up in the newsfeed
post with short videos quotes quizzes
polls and links to other web sites are
now being demoted so what can you as a
business do about this that's not an
easy question and many businesses are
still searching for the answer to this
but let me give you a few tips let's
look at today's top ranking factors in
Facebook top ranking factors in the
Facebook algorithm for the clean up of
the news feed businesses use their posts
to get people to click we call this link
bait to watch a video or view an image
by hovering over it these were all
passive actions nothing to do with
engagement in the new algorithm Facebook
now looks at three interactions
commenting sharing and reacting
commenting is at the core of the updated
Facebook algorithm posts that will lead
to high volume of
we'll show hi in the newsfeed these are
the posts to generate conversations
between people comment baiting is
definitely a no-no in Facebook these
days Facebook will demote posts that use
engagement baits like comment vote react
or share the algorithm will also reward
posts that are being shared
Facebook likes posts that are shared
within messenger and also business posts
that have engagement when shared by
friends but sharing alone is not enough
Facebook will favour those posts that
are shared and lead to conversations
between people
Facebook also likes it when you use
reactions although not as powerful as
comments and shares but it remains a
form of active engagement Facebook will
promote your business posts to more
people when people used to reactions
buttons on your posts so here are the
new tactics that will help you increase
your organic reach of your business
posts call for quality instead of
quantity post once a day instead of five
times a day understand and analyze your
fans check when they are online and post
accordingly think about your content
create specifically for Facebook and use
video and Facebook life Facebook life is
a key tool that will help you improve
your organic reach there is also a
little secret in Facebook called see
first when somebody likes your page it
is set at default when they like your
page which means all your business posts
will go through the Facebook algorithm
but when you set it as C first your post
will guaranteed show up at the top of
the newsfeed of your fan analyze your
posts and see which posts have lots of
engagement recycle these posts or boost
them with advertising learn from other
Facebook pages experiment with your
content and certainly make sure that you
will reply on every comment you are
getting another way of driving your
organic
which is to start using facebook groups
Facebook has revamped the group
functionality recently and are promoting
groups to be used by businesses as well
and this brings us back to the basics of
marketing by implementing these new
algorithm changes Facebook now forces
businesses to understand their customer
to understand their target audiences to
understand their challenges their
motivations what they like to interact
with what they care about because only
then will you be able to create content
that sparks emotion because emotions
will generate comments likes and shares
the future of the Facebook news feeds so
what will happen with the news feeds
when we look into the future the news
feed has been around for more than 10
years now and the concept has become a
bit outdated obviously it won't
disappear straight away but there are
many new features emerging that will
drive new types of engagement if we look
at stories messaging Facebook life and
community features like marketplace
dating these are areas where you don't
need a newsfeed and where you naturally
find more engagement Instagram is a good
example of this its effect that today's
intagram users spend more time in
looking at people's stories than
spending time on the Instagram newsfeed
but for now make sure you understand the
newsfeed and you understand the Facebook
algorithm because that will put you in
an excellent position to take advantage
of everything that Facebook has to offer
here are the highlights of this lesson
recently Facebook announced that it
would update the Facebook algorithm to
only show posts in the newsfeed to lead
to genuine conversations between people
as a result organic reach for business
posts on Facebook has dropped to the
lowest position ever most businesses now
understands that to reach their audience
on Facebook they have to pay to play
which means using Facebook Ads
fortunately there are still ways to beat
the new Facebook algorithm using
Facebook live is one of them hi there if
you like this video subscribe to the
simple learn YouTube channel and click
here to watch similar videos to nerd up
and get certified click here